jeder schweizer mehr machen arbeiten
kinder und jugendliche interessiert das
nicht die diskussion die jetzt kriege
geführt worden ist
rüdiger sie wollen da geht nichts sagen
die wollen eine ehrliche
abschlussprüfung haben digitalisierung
in deutschland deshalb bin ich ja auch
aus der wirtschaft raus in die politik
hinein gegangen weil ich gesagt habe wir
haben fast alles verschlafen und sind
vielleicht noch exportweltmeister noch
dieses jahr aber dann ist vorbei warum
beide nicht erkannt haben was die
zukunft braucht wir haben viel zu viel
gelabert wir brauchen ergebnisse die
kinder müssen in die schule in den
schulen ein
wir sind rein die werden es nicht
schaffen durch unsere mangelhafte welche
welt digitalisierung die wir hier haben
ich habe selber eine lern stück von hier
über 300 jugendliche
wir sind ständig am telefonieren mit den
sozialen unzufriedenheit die
nachfolgenden jugendliche timo immer
raus aus der engeren und sie wollen raus
sie wollen was lernt öffentlich tief
werden durch die diskussion eine gesamte
generation in eine schieflage bringen
und da sag ich ganz einfach auf zu
schwätze macht was macht was immer
machen machen nicht zurückschauen alles
andere funktionieren